maremmani bella genti ragazzi e
benvenuti qui sono video sono vari
generi siamo tornati su ed è contento
selena di fare questo episodio lo vedevo
carica all'inizio peccato che non
l'avete vista per ora era carichissima
aveva un sacco voglia era proprio
pimpante gli dei ragazzi stavolta di
fare il top del mese partiamo con stile
diamond tanto per cominciare in allegria
vero selena o sera era meglio come sony
messa prima da idea come cazzo fatto
vivere mi sembra la strada e copy di a
pazienti che sorgeva e raffa cuadrado
ragazzina sto sentendo la sua sentito un
botto l'india come la sentivo
questo è un diamante di ed è per te te
lo regalo 99 per c'è il tempo profero 90
perfetto per la mia idea di cambiare
stile di livelli in questo momento non è
stata proprio il massimo delle idee
porca eva schifosa incastrata nel duomo
sono i problemi
ultimamente server i tempi di scaletta
un gioco che non fa per me zia facciamo
un patto siti dove lo so trucchi make up
qualsiasi cosa che piace alle donne ogni
domenica pro fai tu ti prego ziano
bisogno fosse fonti maggio che la sta
roba
ciò che a praia valeria propria farsa
parti in live ci ho messo una ri assist
e un po te lo meriti c'è effettivamente
sono contento perché vada male bertè zio
incenerita nell'etna dai quanti problemi
per centrare un buco ad ascoltarmi zia
non è quello che penso
queste queste ora non godo per il finale
godo un porco molto il flip parte ii e
parte ii da parte c'è grazie stava
entrando in un punto dove per farlo ti
puoi nella live ci ho messo 12 anni
non so come diavolo già stavo facendo
adesso e infatti non è che ci sono
riuscito però quei quadri
quando le figlie ti scrivono nei momenti
sbagliati porca eva non posso rispondere
alla figura che sto giocando a rugby
imortacci mi sa di che cosa sto facendo
la mia vita azzecca lo sto battle flip
mango buehlmann e rimaneva se rimaneva
la [ __ ] di primavera a va previsto la
lazio ne quindi si è fatta avanti perché
sono cougar
anche se l'ho fatta se c'è in groppa
trovo sto maledetto piano rialzato nel
vuoto stage in bilico con avanza dai zio
che se vede che ci ha mangiato di
vitello altro giorno
niente annunciato però almeno un
incastro niente ragazzi avere questo è
il massimo del bottoli mezzo scassato un
gas
basta a proposito selena quel ragazzo
che gli schiavi io non me cago le altre
cioè nel senso montate di prendere cioè
stavo scherzando la del ceo della [ __ ]
beh ragazzi 99,9 per cento il prossimo
produzione non altro i posti perché
adesso ammonito il rock singh con gli
imporsi col prima erano una cosa che
staccata dall'altra
adesso hanno dovuto unire le cose perché
non dovuto unire le cose le sapete unire
porca eva giara difficile fare un
prossimo erano difficili da fare uno
spaccato dall'altro c'è la difficile da
far l'impossibile larice l'affare al
rock swing qualche variazione ammoniti è
diventato impossibile almeno riuscito
almeno quello greg gable rocket un razzo
che puoi prendere controllare chi ha mai
sentito una roba del genere marrazzo
portatile due settimane fa visto che me
gente varcava che tra l'altro è lo
sfondo dallo stesso magari anche il
livello 6
ma sti ragazzi
[Musica]
oddio a effetto elastico lo stomaco che
figata
vabbè sticazzi di impossible poco 99 per
cento a caso sono riuscito che pirla ma
anche questi stanno andando un botto il
primo metodo di saltare sulla mina il
problema è che devi trovare il tempismo
giusto ma vigliacca se mezza volta
riuscissimo a farlo mi lamento un po
troppo di me stesso ragazzi davis line 2
perché mi dovete far lanciare i miei
bambini
hai visto hai visto perché dobbiamo
avere un figlio perché io sono un padre
capace rock singh lontano e per cento fe
e l'arma facciamoli tutti sti nicchia di
i rokes in dispute questo caso tipico li
faccio tutto ok
è una sfida questa mi sta guardando
negli occhi e mi sta dicendo che sono
uno stronzo è iter di merda
facciamo così io te li gioco questi
livelli trincee col di fascio e poi ti
uccido e poi mi oltre a farmi livelli mi
faccio anche tua madre niente non c'è
verso non ci arrivo non aveva non c'è
una spinta necessaria e possibile
stavo scherzando
piano piano abbastanza bene
la madonna ma io posso cazzo ma ditemelo
è tanto sbaglio uguale prova bene posso
fare ora casacca posso non dolermi e
qualcuno che me lo dica prima archiavata
si si si
vi prego fate entrare i vostri genitori
in questo momento del video potrebbe
sembrare un porta e spinge tira su
se festa è finita marburgo sbagliato one
ma dai cazzo arca la chiara fatto prima
ma dovete smettere di mandarmi messaggi
anti video perché mi scoccio gialla e
difficile porca eva già difficile e
zitti tale zitti [ __ ] aspettate che ce
la faccio il meta che nessuno se la
mediana nessuno pezzo legata li mortacci
tua madre eva tanto qua
[Musica]
era tanto difficile devi launcher hard
come se fosse tanto difficile lanciare i
bambini suo gioco beh diciamo che posso
ancora migliorare ragazzi piano un
attimo ma anche caso è successo mi sa
che non ho centrato con la moneta mai
nella vita
adesso sì
[Musica]
tutto è bene quel che finisce bene tanto
passa al casco per cento hard ad
accentrare buco selena ora come sono
bravo visto non ti fidare mai di me
perché sbaglio tutto io ho come cazzo
fatto a morire ma dai era bellissimo
portare roba incredibile maradona
e vabbè quanto professional suo salto
bull è che c'è in questo episodio ci
sono diversi problemi selena tanti o
impiegarla guarda ciao perdere vera che
facciamo l'ultimo decente perché per
l'amor di dio ci fosse mezza volta il
bot shas destra prossimo kokhba tornando
ma sia molto grande e le coca cola due
leve viste poche eccole meraviglioso
guarda che la poca fa male dai zio
impregnati almeno un ultimo livello
fammelo bene per favore per favore dopo
anni di epic movie sconce diverrà un po
di dignità in questo gioco è tutto
minchia lunga sta roba
c'è veramente neanche rocco siffredi
così l'umbro chi vuole intendere intenda
tu non intendere amore o mamma mia
quanto è stato difficile far salva
quanto è stato difficile quanto non lo
voglio più fare nella mia vita
la vera che suoni spero che vi sia
piaciuto spero che selena sia stata di
compagnia io credo di non voler giocare
più è più vista la mia vita ma questo è
un fatto che dico e ripeto dal decimo
episodio siamo a sapere sarà bellissimo
e cit ragazzi cosa siete piaciuti al
momento e mi piace anche a l'isola ciò
che come la descrizione sociale
significativi ci vediamo con un prossimo
video bella ragazzi
[Musica]